[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con donde hoy
hablaremos sobre la delicada situación
política y social que se vive en mianmar
tras el golpe de estado militar que se
llevó a cabo el pasado primero de
febrero tras estos hechos han sido miles
los ciudadanos que se han enfrentado en
las calles contra las fuerzas de
seguridad que han sido reprimidos hasta
con munición real causando la muerte de
al menos cuatro personas por ello saludo
en este momento carros sardiña
periodista y autor del libro the burning
de la brand a history of the roy inia
fire y gracias carlos por estar aquí con
nosotros en francés 24 las jornadas de
protestas masivas contra el golpe de
estado militar en mianmar sigan
aumentando cuéntanos cuál ha sido el rol
del ejército hermano en estos últimos
años y cómo ha sido percibido
actualmente por la sociedad
bueno el ejército birmano
estuvo en el poder durante casi cinco
décadas y en 2011 decidió iniciar una
transición a lo que ellos llamaron una
democracia disciplinada
la transición más o menos funcionaba
ansan sutil a la líder de la oposición
democrática no en las elecciones en 2015
pero el ejército continuaba siendo
bastante impopular pero bueno la
constitución asegura un importante papel
político al ejército con lo cual la
constitución asegura que son les asegura
inmunidad les asegura que sus intereses
económicos que son bastante grandes
están protegidos etcétera etcétera lo
cual hace este golpe de estado
especialmente desconcertante porque el
ejército tenía una posición de poder
bastante grande incluso más que el
gobierno civil ahora carlos a esta junta
militar justifica este golpe del pasado
primero de febrero alegando que las
elecciones de noviembre las segundas
elecciones democráticas en el país
fueron fraudulentas que tan creíbles son
estas denuncias y como ustedes lo dijo
si ellos casi que gozaban más poder que
el civil porque entonces hicieron este
golpe de estado
bueno las elecciones es posible que
hubiera algunas irregularidades
pero probablemente esas irregularidades
no alteraron el resultado de las
elecciones y observadores
internacionales como el cárter center
and han dado el visto bueno a las
elecciones con lo cual parece que las
acusaciones de fraude electoral son más
bien una excusa
es muy difícil saber por qué el ejército
ha dado ha decidido dar este golpe en
este momento porque el ejército de
birmania especialmente en los los altos
mandos es una de las instituciones más
opacas del mundo
es muy difícil saber qué es lo que
piensa cómo piensan y cuál es su proceso
mental yo mi teoría es que ellos estaban
cada vez más
impacientes con ancho de su chico en el
gobierno danza en su chip a la que veían
no tanto como una amenaza a sus
intereses porque ella realmente nunca lo
ha sido y ha sido muy cauta a la hora de
tratar con el ejército pero sí como a
alguien quizá demasiado arrogante que no
estaba colaborando lo suficientemente
con el ejército entonces quizás hayas
habido una serie de circunstancias que
les han llevado a irritarse enormemente
con ella y a dar este golpe ahora
rápidamente carlos estos hechos de
violencia de los últimos días han
llevado a la comunidad internacional a
imponer sanciones contra varios miembros
del ejército birmano además investigue
una posible respuesta regional con los
países de la asean que dará efectiva
serán estas sanciones y cuál es la mejor
manera de enfrentar esta crisis yo creo
que las sanciones no van a ser demasiado
efectivas durante la anterior junta
militar de 1988 a 2011 la comunidad
internacional impulsó sanciones y la
junta militar era capaz de sobrevivir e
incluso al aislar el país
eran capaces de sobrevivir y de
mantenerse en el poder
el papel de la asean de la asociación de
naciones del sudeste asiático podría ser
bastante determinante porque muchos de
ellos son socios comerciales
especialmente tailandia singapur los
generales suelen tener sus cuentas
bancarias en bancos en singapur etcétera
etcétera pero las sean tiene una
política de no intervención en asuntos
internos de los países que hacen muy
difícil que vayan a hacer algo al
respecto
perdón si es difícil saber cómo el
contexto internacional puede influir en
los generales carros gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en este segmento de
france 24 que tenga usted un feliz resto
de día y ustedes continuar con nosotros
para más actualización informativa
[Música]